[Musique]
je vous fais ici le pari que très
bientôt
l'humanité notre espèce deviendra vegan
mais commençons par le commencement ça
veut dire quoi exactement
le véganisme
beaucoup d'entre vous y voyez peut-être
un régime alimentaire en effet mais ça
va beaucoup beaucoup plus loin que ça on
pourrait représenter le véganisme comme
une éthique une éthique dans laquelle on
estime qu'il n'y a aucune raison valable
d'exploiter ou de tuer des êtres vivants
et sensibles si on n'a pas besoin de le
faire
si on n'a pas besoin de le faire
et avons nous besoin de le faire
j'imagine que beaucoup d'entre vous vous
aimez les animaux
peut-être que finalement la plupart
d'entre nous avons déjà commencé ce
chemin évolutionnaire vers le véganisme
alors j'entends souvent dire oui celle
et le mouvement vegan un humain égal il
va chez guerlain poissons
n'ont par contre il s'agit de ce qu'on
appelle légal considération de données
en fait le droit de vivre animaux tout
comme les droits de l'homme garantissent
le droit de vivre aux êtres humains
alors concrètement une personne lagan ne
mange plus les animaux ni ce qu'ils
produisent le miel
ne se vêtit plus de laine ou de cuir se
posait à la chasse de loisirs à
rechercher des alternatives à
l'expérimentation animale s'oppose aussi
à la corrida et toute forme de
maltraitance
alors si je vous parlais d'un monde
réellement devenu vegan au delà des
clichés qu'on entend souvent allons-y
dans ce monde là dans ce monde là on a
redonné aux écosystèmes et à la vie
sauvage 25 % des surfaces
autrefois cultivées
25% et si on ajoute
les pâturages les zones d'élevage
extensif alors on a rendu à la nature
80% des espaces que nous exploitions
auparavant les forêts repousse les
animaux sauvages où circulent on en
croise peut-être de plus en plus souvent
ils ne nous suit pas ils n'ont aucune
raison de le faire les océans aussi se
repeuple poissons coraux plancton et
retrouvent leur taux d'acidité normal
la planète revis à votre avis quel
pourcentage de la production agricole
mondiale va dans nos assiettes
80%
50%
21% seulement et oui 53 % de la
production agricole mondiale va non pas
pour nous les humains mais pour les
animaux que les humains vous mettre dans
leur assiette
10 % vont pour l'industrie et 16%
partant gaspillage le giec nous rappelle
que pour un kilo de produit animal dans
notre assiette il aura fallu 38 kg de
matière végétale pour nourrir le dit
animal matière végétale sèche en plus on
a beau tirer l'eau du calcul
pas terrible comme un rendement tout ça
dans ce monde là non seulement les
océans les ferait en repousser parlons
aussi de ce que nous raconte l'american
dietetic association la plus grande 100
mille personnes un monde et qui nous dit
déjà dès 2009 dès 2009 que un régime
végétal sévère bon pour la santé à tous
les âges de la vie y compris pour les
enfants les femmes enceintes
et les sportifs de haut niveau des
athlètes novak djokovic ne vous dira
certainement pas le contraire champion
du monde de tennis avec une alimentation
végétale
venus williams sinon plus et 1,10 nous
sommes les plus forts du monde ce qui
s'appelle patrick bibeau mian qui nous
rappelle que les animaux les plus forts
les gorille les éléphants les buffles on
joue tous de végétaux quelque chose peut
être de plus essentiel encore dans ce
monde là nous avons aussi changé à
verser le réchauffement climatique
alors comment et bien tout simplement
parce que de fait le premier nous avons
arrêté la production massive de méthane
vingt cinq fois plus toxique puissant
que le co2 25 fois plus et nous avons
arrêté en 2019 j'ai eu l'occasion de
faire partie de ce qui ce qu'on appelle
pays review qui donc vérifier une
publication scientifique qui visait à
calculer quel pourcentage de gaz à effet
serre proviennent de l'élevage un
travail de fond réalisé par le chercheur
ça y laissera aux indo américain dans le
prestigieux journal of ecological signs
saleh se demandait mettait en doute en
fait les chiffres produits par la fao la
food and agriculture organization et qui
nous stipule que 14 et demi pour cent
des gaz à effet de serre viennent de
l'élevage ça fait déjà beaucoup le giec
les états les journalistes ont repris ce
chiffre comme parole d'évangile
alors il fallait tout reprendre à zéro
tout recalculer sans parti pris sans
enjeu financier derrière et là je vous
laisse deviner quel pourcentage de gaz à
effet serre et l'a trouvé deux fois plus
trois fois plus 1
s'il faut plus
87 % des gaz à effet de serre
aujourd'hui viennent de l'élevage
quelque part ça m'a rendu optimiste il
suffit de se mettre à aimer et à prendre
soin des animaux
pour sauver notre propre espèce
le sont systémiques
il n'y a pas longtemps j'avais eu une
conversation avec une amie une de ces
conversations habituelles sur le
véganisme et comme tant de gens elle
sait très bien que on n'a pas besoin de
manger des animaux elle sait très bien
la souffrance qu'il y a comme 21% des
français elle sait qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'émettre dans son assiette elle concède
que elle même n'a plus aucune raison
rationnelle de consommer des produits
animaux alors je lui demande mais
et pourquoi ne changeait pas qu'y a t'il
qui te retiens
et ben là j'ai peur
et a peur de quoi
eh ben j'ai j'ai peur de mettre le doigt
dans l'engrenage
j'ai peur de la personne que je vais
devenir si je pousse l'analyse jusqu'au
bout de ne plus pouvoir aller au
restaurant faire des barbecues avec mes
amis j'ai peur de ce que comment ça va
se passer avec mes enfants j'ai peur de
1 comment ça va se passer au travail
comment vont me regarder j'ai peur de ne
pas savoir cuisiner peut-être que vous
ressentez vous aussi ce même malaise
peut-être maintenant même comme je vous
en parle les sociologues et les
spécialistes des sciences sociales ont
un nom pour ça on appelle ça le paradoxe
de la viande le paradoxe de la viande il
se produit exactement quand deux espaces
cognitifs en où se confrontent
s'affrontent deux logiques qui
s'opposent l'une dit
j'aime des animaux je ne veux pas leur
faire de mal
et l'autre dit je les tue je les mange
beaucoup essayé de résoudre ce conflit
intérieur en disant on te manger les
animaux et ne pas les faire souffrir
un message largement relayée par les
lobbys de l'élevage ils tirent là
probablement leurs dernières cartouches
regardons les choses en face prendre
soin des animaux hockey
cela veut dire que nous allons mettre en
extérieur
70 milliards d'animaux que nous tuons
chaque année dont la plupart viennent d
enfer concentrationnaire dans lesquelles
on les garde
60 milliards impossible donc vous
mangerez de la viande du fromage de
temps en temps ça vaudra très cher ça
n'aura absolument pas résolu la question
du réchauffement climatique et encore
moins celle de la souffrance animale
cela vaut-il vraiment vraiment le coup
alors si vous vous retrouvez dans cette
conversation j'ai eu avec mon ami ou
dans ce paradoxe de la viande comme tant
de personnes
il n'y a rien à craindre il suffit
simplement
déjà de les confronter ce que je viens
de vous dire faites vous votre propre
avis regardez les publications
scientifiques regarder les nombreux
documentaires qui existe sur internet et
si vous considérez que les animaux ont
le droit de vivre comme nous et que vous
utilisez votre raison votre rationalité
avec courage parce que sans demande du
courage et bien votre chemin vers une
humanité vegan aura commencé sans aucun
doute
ça donnerait quoi un monde devenu vegan
par désir une fois passé l'océan
fantasmatique des peurs
vous voyez le véganisme au delà de son
évidence rationnelle et des horreurs
qu'ils rejettent a besoin de se
construire
une vision créatrice et désirable ce que
j'essaye de faire
alors
prenez du temps
avec vous même
prenez soin de vous ne vous jugez pas
vous fait pas mal ne devenez pas un
tyran avec vous mais moi ou avec les
autres
écoutez ce mouvement intérieur ce
mouvement évolutionnaire
cette petite voix qui
faites-les confiance
vous y trouverez là la plus grande des
aventures l'évolution de vous même je
vous remercie
[Musique]